most of the modern world operates from a
system of individualism a system that
puts the fate of the individual in the
hands of the individual if you are
successful it's because you worked hard
and smart and you deserve if you're a
failure it is because you didn't and you
deserve it
this system of thought and reasoning is
widely endorsed by many of the world's
leading cultures it is the basis of
capitalism and arguably the basis of
human nature it is the reason why we try
why we apply creativity why we compete
to progress humankind because we believe
that our actions determine our fate that
we all control the course of our own
lives but this begs the question how in
control are we real how much stake
should we place in the ideal that we are
the sole driver of our life it appears
to be true that we humans do have some
ability to influence the direction in
which our life goes hardwork strategy
and ingenuity can increase the
likeliness of achieving ones goals and
desired lifestyle but it also appears to
be true that oftentimes what we want
does not align with what we get that
life operates on its own wavelengths
some amount out of reach from our
volition and control fundamentally we
live in a reality that we do not fully
understand and as a result there is an
entire realm of uncertainty and
arbitrariness associated with everything
we experience including our fortunes and
misfortunes
we are not the sole pilots of our life
we cannot choose whom we are born to or
to avoid a tragedy or to be tall or
small white or black dumb or smart we
are all forced to submit to our DNA and
the instances of luck or tragedy that we
are exposed to in life the truth is
things happen for good or for bad but
oftentimes things that happen happen
just because they happen not because of
intent but because of chance and the
things that happen out of chance hold
the same amount of weight and influence
on our lives as the things that happen
out of intent humanity may operate out
of individuality but the universe
operates from a place of collectivity
and so we must learn how to live with
the burden of existing with an
individualistic mind and culture while
simultaneously existing within a
collective reality we should try to do
everything in our power to influence our
life we should feel motivated and
invigorated to work towards goals and
success but we should also acknowledge
the realm of life that is beyond our
control so we can be reasonably
indifferent towards the fortunes and
misfortunes we experience so we do not
become disillusioned if our fate does
not align with our intentions or become
inflated with narcissism if it does it
is not only our achievements that matter
wealthy or poor smart or foolish famous
or unknown we all remain in the same
boat just as confused and as vulnerable
to life as the next our quality of life
depends on our ability to admit this
roll with the punches and stay inspired
to pursue success for the mere sake of
the
suit to function partly as an observer
of our own life whose primary objective
is to be entertained by life's
uncertainty for both the good and the
bad thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder